[Music]
Hellboy verse Thanos what we think oh
boy versus man oh man
he would just you know I mean it'd be a
good fight
that sounds guys pretty powerful but I
think Hellboy would win the emotional
fight by just making fun of the very
serious way he takes himself in his
Malthusian philosophies
I think Hellboy would have a field day
with that and just like you know cut him
down to size with some good one-liners
you can't beat him physically just right
you should oh yeah exactly just
psychologically abuse
[Music]
yes the human side
[Music]
we do but it's not gonna work you know
cuz I'm a Capricorn and you huh boy he
has no love interest and he's a shredded
daddy so like why does my god is it two
words that I never want to hear put
together like I want to hear like
shredded chicken on my sandwich I never
want to hear
shredded daddy ever again but I've heard
it and I can't be unhurt um yes but you
know what he does have in the movie
which i think is so again it's like
another sort of unique thing which I
love is he's attracted to the villain
he'd be predisposed to a supernatural
creature that like as opposed to the
human world which reveals him he turns
away from a certain aspect of himself
that's inherent his destiny and
theoretically genetic nature and to be
able to cut off that piece of himself to
do the right thing if that choice
doesn't hurt to me it doesn't feel
resonant so we I wanted it really to
hurt and that was so the impulse for him
not being able to have romance and him
actually having to be alone or in an
outcast
okay I'd appreciate a prophecy with more
relatable steak you guys crank it up
yeah the apocalypse is no joke you know
I mean when it hits it's gonna be bloody
it's gonna be violent and we're not
gonna shy away from that we're not gonna
sugarcoat the apocalypse for you you
can't yeah
[Music]